thank you
we are live here in studio we're live
we are law lavash it we are literally
live you're plugging in your [ __ ] uh
Nintendo [ __ ] bin for it is it's
like 30% that that is the beauty of
having a [ __ ] uh you know Gameboy a
gameboy as a phone if I take a phone
call that lasts more than an hour now at
this point I'm risking not being able to
texture
you haven't charged your phone in two
days three days four days
wait what sayst to be honest no I really
be honest no don't do a gag okay no no
I'm trying to be honest oh but I flew
here on Sunday just the fact that you
flew like if I get on a flight it's an
iPhone I get off the plane I'm like I've
got to get a chart like I have to just
stop and charge my [ __ ] because it's -
there's too many things happening but on
your calculator that you can also take
calls on yeah you charge it what no I
left I weekly I think I charged it
yeah bi-weekly I think I charged it
uncharged it and it was ready to go at
like 2:00 p.m. to 11:00 a.m. this time
on Sunday so 48 hours but I'm down to
30% I did take some phone calls
Adam argent Samoans where it's like in
and out of service so it like really
draws a lot more out of it where you
staying you got a Airbnb or you know
some owns go yeah
welcome to punch truck sports everybody
wear sports wins winners sport
considerate sucked Aaron's here Aaron
how are you
he's racing to a mic I'm good thank you
man that was Aaron how many hormones do
you think pools finishes with 700 or no
when's he retire I think yeah I think he
has some ridiculous he's like three
years left on his deal yeah I know it's
that's not about his deal but yes yeah
we'll get three a year now something
like that
24 yeah 24 home runs a year you think
you're asking Millions
he's making no no no way more nah cuz he
can play as long as he wants
yes so it's really not about that he can
even find a team that will start him or
DHM and baseball isn't like a UFC or NFL
or whatever you like you get one can
caution you like [ __ ] man this 26 year
old might be done because that baseball
player and then become a d h and just
like i you know all i do is swing a bat
i swing the bat 14 times a week oh yeah
i was saying about a week I don't think
about week I was doing that number so 27
times a week I'm swinging a bat I might
strike out a might not but that gets so
a million dollars of swing a million
bucks its way when you do that you're
like this [ __ ] making a mitt
he's in his late 30s a million dollars
oh really what's your math that's crazy
off we're a million that was a swing
even if it's not even per hit I'm saying
oh yeah if you go by a week no I was
doing he swings a bat
27 times a week yeah yeah yeah you're
right yeah a year don't a week a week
not a swing so $70,000 a swing something
like that yeah he could sign a contract
for a million a year and he wouldn't he
would rather retire no I don't think so
he's never been here for the money but a
million a year I might argue he's in it
for the money so fun no I would proles
to stop and fought he's still hitting
home runs he's enjoying playing with
teammates he's joined talking up Mike
Trout we offered him 200 milliliters he
wanted to forty so I mean like he wants
when was that when was that that was
before this morning yeah I was on your
way here on your way here on your way
before he left but that's different
that's [ __ ] seven years ago he knows
he's not the player anymore oh yeah yeah
but you shall take that money this is
amazing though cuz when they got rid of
home st. Louis it was like he was
instantly worse they got out of that
pools game at the right time but there's
also that thing of like there's the same
element of like we were talking about
before the show started with LeBron
where he like this
twenty-seven-year-old lebron coming to
the lakers but he sells tickets he makes
money he's so he's generating revenue
yeah for the Lakers so they're not just
revenue at the exact same thing he's
doing that pools is doing yeah like a
view comp like let's say pools goes to
the Brewers
yeah he's worth a certain mountain air
that it's that's for sure they're like
hey man our season seats are now sold
out because this famous guy is here the
famous on old I just I can't give you
jr. to like another contract Barry Bonds
Barry Bonds has signed with the Brewers
just like who has who has 499 home runs
like who's the ideas play for the
Orioles not Cal but the other great
Eddie Murray no he's got does he yeah
he's good no not now the 3000 hit guy
though anymore I think and 500 home runs
he does have far but okay there was such
a CO people that are like oh me but
maybe the pho mock Fred McGriff McGriff
I'm down I'm down ride him for a year
let him get his 500 he's already in the
Hall of Fame let him come out get his
500 he's not in the Hall of Fame yeah
he's not let him get his 500 I'll be in
yeah the health wait another five years
she be should be should be don't you
think yeah I think so I do they're just
like he was never ever BP his time with
the Braves he was great with the Braves
yeah silly we know his name still that
means he's famous we know his nickname
yeah Crime Dog
yeah great nickname McGriff the crime
does anybody listening remember McGruff
the Crime Dog of course well they just
came out with a new commercial
ferma gross is that right Geico or
something and they're like oh I did see
that I did see that he has an idea Jamie
you're right you're right let me bring
that up guys it's nice to have already
in the studio welcome back alright nice
so we're going to skank fest now the
basketball thing has taken a what that
way
right on the table well just spit right
on the table I think what did you spit
out I don't want to don't let Mike see
that
don't let Aaron see that and if I see it
I'm a Pew selfie bastard okay here's
this case wide open turns out the
principal get a tip he whippy I'm
serious as long as people talk baby talk
to dogs you can count on Geico saving
folks money fifteen minutes could save
you 15% or more on car insurance
guys exactly McGruff please use our new
sponsor Geico gecko for all your savings
in five minutes or less gets you 15% or
more off all your claim dog needs that's
not really a McGruff commercial as much
as there's a spoof and I go grammar so
yeah so and then so no no no no all
right please it's floating I'm actually
just gonna look this way there's a
baseball bat here and I'm thinking about
using it on your I'm just looking I'm
just looking that way Oh Thank You Aaron
that's me because then I have to look at
him it's not cool it's not cool you can
get more but did you guys see the who
was it Aaron that was no get around it
oh good it's a Holocaust around it
that's true how many times a lady said
that to me it was all custody it around
it no you can eat yourself around there
I'm like you know what yeah on the right
side get that left lip eat around it
around it who was the Kinsler somebody
it's like a homerun jacker they just did
like a batting practice but he had a
[ __ ] aluminum bat aluminum bat and
what did it was do you know who I have a
homerun console it was on it was on ESPN
the other day I was like in the top you
know plays of the day or whatever and it
was that boring of a day of news where
they're like look at this guy just
[ __ ] off with a [ __ ] aluminum bat
brow everything there's like Justin it
was hitting the scoreboard and like
denting scoreboards how about this Major
League Baseball during the all-star
break you have the home run derby shirt
then you also have a very short five six
seven plate whatever he's taken ten
swings only you you lop off the first
deck and you can only hit two upper deck
or more is a home run anything below
that and you hit with aluminum bats cool
let him [ __ ] launch them or forget
about it
if Major League Baseball players had
aluminum bats three pitchers a year
would die I would die and then when
whatever this was like two or three days
ago and I can't remember who was jacking
him every single pitch was upper Decker
hitting the scoreboard and like denting
it like
so [ __ ] gross you are so gross like
you would fart on a sandwich and then
somehow that sandwich would be better
for you you would open up a sandwich
fart on it close it and then eat it and
be like that's what's up
what am i favorite things in some areas
popcorn no matter kettle corn you said
with a Comedy Store
I didn't people that can I have
sometimes the dollar before she moves
you up to two dollars member that yeah
so everyone was like comments sure and
so you I take something like this you
know have like five of them eat for ya
and then put the other one in my mouth
like comforting more and then I just
have it and then drop that one in when I
took others so it's just a soaking wet
piece of pie think about it and then
they eventually get it and they're like
that's like terrorism I AMA so that's an
emotional terror it's a form of
terrorism it's a form of terrorism yeah
yeah and I do it for the grace of Allah
I feel very powerful having an aluminum
bat in my hand while you are eating
cinnamon toast crunch its assertive man
Joel scrunch the cinnamon toast crunch
makers with toast crunch burger man
toast crunch you'll see t see ya see t
see is that you know the people who
started cereal Kellogg's were really
only interested in giving people a
healthy full grain option for eating
that's why they were corn only wanted
full grains and then what happened and
then they were like I just put a bunch
of sugar give it to fat Americans yeah
fat dummies no then money happened oh
yeah
like oh we can get rich by making kids
hideous and fat and [ __ ] that is
beautiful
yeah that is not beautiful fat
accentuates the other parts of you that
is beautiful like oh then body Wayne
explain their body so gross you're not a
pretty cool person though I don't know
so cool person there works I'm not
looking at anything else about them I no
longer find you threatening there's a
cause you look like you're gonna die
soon but you know what you're a nice
person to get to know doesn't make
people funnier though some people
oh yeah oh yeah of course often they
still funny come on guys
come on stop who's a friend stop too
soon too soon too soon not too soon
actually what did happen this year's
last trip like I am whenever October of
last year all right so it's been the
past yeah it's not too soon like it was
off if you died on this oh god no that's
what he wanted to do that's all it was a
big ruse oh no god damn it ah wrong with
you I'm so plastered by Geico got a
little super there I think probably with
the water there you go
no no no no I made it so much worse
agreed you guy who ate it agreed you
have more money than anybody else on the
show but you're eating I wouldn't eat
that's why I'm sleeping on an underpass
and I wouldn't and I'm like yeah I care
about myself too much do that to me
so today was meant to be the hot dog
there mm-hmm not gonna be no hey please
taking a hiatus if you want it it'll be
okay he'll be on the live skank fest
podcast would not be doing the hot dogs
there I was agreed upon we are hanging
off big J's bet when and if Triple E
comes back to the podcast it is unclear
we'll be paying off the hot dog bet then
okay I will do my best to pay off the
USA chant and the begging can I ask you
this about that like the two that I have
to pay off one where I mean I have to
wear shock collar on the show that's
fine
we just haven't bought a shock collar
Sam seems to think that bet is he gets
to tase my balls for [ __ ] two and a
half straight hours that's probably not
what is gonna happen and then my other
one which is difficult like yours where
I have to have a makeup artist I got a
dress like a [ __ ]
I got a makeup artist just get some lady
to [ __ ] put makeup on you nothing
really
lady you know what I mean yeah whatever
somebody you know have to borrow women's
clothes but that's like an elaborate
thing you're too are also elaborate the
USA chant is not as nada you're saying
oldest thing is great the homeless thing
is a lot that could take you ten hours I
think
multiple multiple days I what I wanted
to do good be I'm here was the corner of
La Cienega and Santa Monica that turn
lane that makes you turn if you're
coming in the West and you turn north so
you're coming from the west from the
beach when you oh yeah yeah yeah turn
lane that double long turn lane I could
just go door like car to car I think I
could do it that way but it might take
two full days but I like Hollywood
Boulevard if you just have a funny sign
and you're just sitting on the street
with a funny sign like I saw a guy the
other day that had a sign that said work
as a possible needs need bullets for my
gun that's what his sign said I'm like
that's pretty [ __ ] funny sign and I
threw him a buck cuz I'm like funny sign
yeah you know you like New York what do
you gotta raise $40 that's a little hat
it's a lot it's brutal I mean I might
get a dollar hear that but mostly I
think I'd be getting like twenty-two
cents and though there's been stairs and
like looking past and no one's giving
you change if you have change that's
your Thor now I mean you have like a hat
or some sort of like thing but no one's
gonna like give you three pennies it's
really a dollar it's usually a buck like
20 cents left over outside of 7-eleven
if you set up camp outside a 7-eleven
park there's no place to do it's got a
think that lives away better place in
New York this nobody sees homeless
people ride around like a man Chinese
Theatre like that hole right by Kimmel
on that whole neck of the woods is you
could literally sit indian-style and
probably make 8 bucks an hour why is
that why is it different in here there's
so many homeless in New York and they're
not put in one position that put
everywhere here we have mostly downtown
homeless okay is it worse there than
here yeah it's far worse it's in like a
redis things like the number one city in
America for homeless is LA and it's the
biggest
problem here growing and it's growing
through that fast Shay is like a
multiple blocks now oh I mean it's
unbelievable you know I was um I don't
remember where I went but I was
somewhere downtown no like my last I
guess girlfriend whatever but she and I
were walking around downtown like having
a day and then we make like a left and a
right and we're just walking rent and
then we found ourselves there in tent
city were like you know and she was very
kind of like scared but it was like
three o'clock on a Saturday or some
afternoon they're not looking for
trouble but there are some but she was
very kind of like scared so she was like
hold my hand like walking real close to
me like whatever am i I went to like his
rights [ __ ] get up your own like what's
up tighty-whities were over a parking
meter outside of like a tent
tighty-whities were underwear
we're like they were drying or something
an alternate explanation I please please
he was happy my to have a Batman he was
having sex inside that tent I didn't
want his roommate coming him oh you mean
the old school like hang a tie on the
door uh-huh
well I didn't get that vibe but I
definitely will never touch another
[ __ ] parking me you can't touch
anything like any public sort of like a
trash bin or the [ __ ] I don't touch
the parking like the crosswalk button oh
dude I was I was uh I did that I was
came from a subway in New York when I
said some this podcast actually and then
I was finger blasting a girl and she got
some weird [ __ ] reaction oh oh yeah I
start bleeding started burning she said
you must have a disease and there was
like no boy I tested fine it was like
they had just [ __ ] toxic shock signal
from [ __ ] subway touching really
yeah you're not joking you're not joking
no you're being honest yeah really
for real Wow yeah well yeah so I shook
up a now I'm George a new move oh can I
shoved it up there and let it go
I was going a different cook house I
always cane sugar cane sugar huh I was
going a different wherever like the new
Lube is Purell and so let's take a
caller caller you're on the air we're on
the air it's blood truck hello
nobody there hey boy no one called in
and called but I'm not taking it yet Oh
take him put him on hold I can't do that
what we don't have that capability here
that's just Skype here's a call what we
don't have the capability of calling
saying hold on one second here's ago
what the [ __ ] was hoho
we could mute I mean Katherine all
you're on the air what's that big body
yeah hey why don't you go [ __ ] yourself
kiss my ass
eat your [ __ ] [ __ ] I hope your
mother dies in a horrible not plane
crash but some sort of like long-term
painful thing maybe your skull gets
slowly slowly crushed unable to [ __ ]
get out oh good I hope it [ __ ]
devours her body I hope it takes one
breast at a time and she tries to
remarry and then [ __ ] can't do it
because their husband or new husbands
like you know what you're disgusting
[ __ ] lose both your tits [ __ ] hang
up with this [ __ ] guys and
that's taking huh that's taking calls Oh
welcome to punch drunk literally wished
his mother cancer and then he goes well
good news she already has cancer and you
go I hope both of her tits fall off I
wanted and you he thought he had there
take a call well I mean I guess I'm
gonna be doing the hot dogs as soon as
Stan gets back if he doesn't get back on
just do it on my own so that was on the
bed that you guys have to do and if he
doesn't get back I will right now but
it's like no files or by Sam snow his
bat no you don't have to do that oh but
I want to you could pay off another bet
with him you could double enough I
couldn't believe he didn't accept it
because sandy Tebow offered to do not
know but he'll get call a [ __ ] if he
[ __ ] let someone else do it for him
he's smart not let that happen but if he
does my other ones that are outstanding
that he doesn't worry oh yeah I said you
can take the two bets that you keep
saying I won't do on him do it anyway
you do my bat you had to take a three
you do
my bets and then I will take a hot dog
in the ass but you don't want to do
nobody wants to do it that's the point
yeah you're wrong this is where you're
wrong
I've been practicing you're looking at
it for the protein somehow in your body
no you're wrong as [ __ ] I love like
having my [ __ ] blown up by something
that looks like a [ __ ] I hear that if
you want to make that gay then I don't
want to be strange we carve a sausage to
make a hot dogs we need to make it like
a muffin top on the end to make it look
like a real [ __ ] you looking at I'm
sorry ah I then is that a call
definitely gets I was wait so when they
call the phone number it doesn't it's
Skype only it goes into Skype that's how
I answer lame why is this here I mean I
am NOT against it I borrowed it for
yesterday's softball game especially we
had awful gaming I was invited I was
here no hello
could we play against some company
called PD president oh we're in a league
we're two league it was an eight-time
all-star show you were not I absolutely
was in what Oh [ __ ] t-bone lesbian
[ __ ] softball no I played tears
bucket here's [ __ ] Muppet Johnny hit
him no I I guarantee I'm better at
baseball in Europe but I'm so much
better at baseball than you are
I can guarantee actually what position
you play I was a pitcher and then I
played story checks out pitcher catcher
story checks out those are real
positions - yeah have you guys here oh
you saw the staircase there my thing in
softball at our level softball is just
hits low grounds to third and you'll
beat it out seventy percent of the time
yeah I own it throws yeah just like
right why mess with a possible public
life just slow grounder to third and put
the pressure on tech who bunts at t-ball
yeah they did there I bunted at t-ball
I'm like bang wheels would you butt it
on Jim Abbott
[Laughter]
poor people didn't yeah hey what if it
what if you weren't major league
baseball you're playing getting a bunch
of money and then I try it until he
proves otherwise what if you're playing
in a rec league and there's a guy with
one arm pitching to you yeah first of
all I am hood you guys but definitely
having laughs and drinks after dinner
later yes yeah I'm telling my girlfriend
or wife I'm like you won't believe how I
got over on this guy feel the dream of
Jim Abbott yeah it's some kind of like
legends compilation it was a catcher I
thought be here there's a catcher with
one arm I so relationally yes I mean in
college it's steel against that that's
weird gross the thing is he knew Jim
Abbott that's why was so great he knew
his IQ of course people gonna bunt at me
that was what I would do so he quickly
learned how to shift that glove yeah
instantly yeah good for him yeah and
then people like you just can't do
anyone but would you guys do it in a rec
league Aaron your first you would
Woodward in a close game win the game
four in a playoff game yeah but not in a
regular game I I would have a lot of
trouble really
I would depend on his attitude
everyone's saying it if he looked like
an [ __ ] up like pumping his fist when
he strikes you out stuff coming is what
not plural fist yeah so low
yeah we're concerned your concern is
looking bad yeah by bunting against what
most of us would call a [ __ ] right
everybody we could agree I think a
scientific yeah how much better was the
California Angels like brand and
everything this Anaheim way better
Anaheim and then they went Anaheim of
Los Angeles like that really different
things will be part of that too I'm sure
the Dodgers aren't set in over there
maybe we can move yeah [ __ ] idiots I
want to crank on homeroom it is bad to
it hold this for like a few minutes just
have it around you and tell me you don't
want to [ __ ] swing it can we all go
swing outside Ivan I mean we would not
have a show happening but we could yeah
I handed that to the wrong
person yeah I really realized that on
Ronde the shooter I really realized I
made a mistake handing Ari Shaffir back
oh good you're gonna swing this towards
my face
no no oh it's fine it's fine
that's what I need that's my boy there's
got to be like signs
you gotta choke up a little bit all I
was all I would do is work on if I was a
baseball player is working my bat flip
it down every surround bat flip [ __ ] it
was stare at the pitcher I would create
fights I'd like I'd want them to try to
beat me in there who is always jealous
of those guys who could do like
basketball tricks and baseball streak
that's oh yeah you can't spin a
basketball your finger
mm-hmm I can I can do it I pop it up
bounce it off my shoulder I'm a wrist or
elbow hopefully you'll do that next
weekend at the skank fest whether you
have three basketball tournament that
Rena ZC sitting in they [ __ ] us guys
go to Ari Shaffir calm for all your
stone fest yeah info that's a great way
to get and find out what's going on and
what is going on is so what we get in
Johnny and I get in a little late and
part of purpose it told you a different
time that part turn was gonna be you
know they later seen and [ __ ] Louis
the [ __ ] lets me know tapeworm know
they can't win so they tried to going
outside the system oh you know what they
did well they told Johnny and I hey
don't take a red-eye Thursday juror
Falls yeah that's absolutely true they
said do not take a red-eye Thursday just
get in
Friday when you get in so then you know
it was cheaper for us to take a red-eye
but I'm like oh you know what that's
cool we won't I know they said that we
wouldn't be able to check in the hotel
and you'll just be sitting around so
don't yeah sure we didn't tell them I
say because kitchen in a room right now
and cuz it can take you nine o'clock it
sounded like really they didn't want to
be from there I was thinking yeah so we
were like okay I don't want to I didn't
want to make it difficult for them to
like run around or pick us up and do all
this sort of [ __ ] so we took a you know
we get in like four well do you think
about that I asked him I was like okay
so what time is about
ball game and they said three and I
emailed her back I was like you know we
don't get in till 3:30 and she goes oh
[ __ ]
and then they scram we're planning it's
Christine Christina whatever our name is
oakerson I don't know they're not a real
name but like she's bad at planning
Christine doesn't know what she's doing
and so that [ __ ] us over or it was
intentional which way do you want it
idiot [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] does the - you
want to be intentionally I mean against
the rules and the spirit of this
tournament or do you want to be your
inept well guess what you're Armenian so
I guess you're inept I mean if I want to
tinfoil hat this up uh-huh yeah they
conspired against us and they're trying
to keep us down and they're trying to
[ __ ] make us look like we don't care
or we can't even be there because
they're afraid of what unlimited fouls
that's our biggest asset unlimited is
area reference Josh Barnes like what you
guys had to old what are you guys gonna
do when I shoot a three right in your
face
I go just I'll block with my knee I go
we're gonna kick you in your [ __ ]
teeth and he goes please don't kick me
so say I'm gonna be there in time
Thursday yeah Sam Sam's there early so
Sam and re and Rena ZZ will be filling
in for me on the first game because I
can't physically make it to the first
game do you know the format of the is it
like double elimination or something no
oh no we ain't got that kind of time so
if you lose the first game heat there
will not it's not just the fort podcast
anymore it's it's lots of comics or
playing on teams okay less like little
wait now if Gary Gulman plays if you
lose the first game though do you not
Joe Vitt Joe Vesey and Gary Gulman get
on team we're done I'm wondering I
wonder how they deal with a [ __ ]
blown out ACL like kicks with a leg kick
while you shoot free throws front leg
kick so if you live before he gets there
though they won't there won't be another
game yes yeah there might be another
game if we win them what you're saying
is team go straight to the hotel take a
nap and then go to your set what time do
you land three thirty forty-five yes and
I wear JFK or LaGuardia JFK JFK
you're gonna bags or just carry nothing
carry on yeah JFK that means you're
gonna you can be in if it's in Brooklyn
it's closer for sure it isn't Brooklyn
the tournaments in Brooklyn from what I
understand then you could be there in 45
minutes okay we'll be there for 30
earliest yeah so an hour and a half
after the first game the autumn roll in
if we go straight like I literally have
up my luggage with me
yeah I would shows everybody hour and a
half later if everything goes smooth no
delay no flight [ __ ] problems no
nothing just bang bang bang bang out I
got my you know we both have just
backpacks everybody playing at the same
time though I think there'll be a few
courts going right so it's okay and
they'll be like probably ten minutes all
the teams go ahead yeah that sucks yeah
it does but we'll still win of course I
mean if it's those four four we promoted
video on patreon for that - that's it
piss me off
yeah he's bringing who's gonna bring a
drone and shoot it with a drone yet but
now do you get what's the point now
we're on the same flight [ __ ] idiot
god damnit oh you're gonna shoot drone
footage yeah I know yeah but now we're
not because they don't want us to win
you know the number one knock we get do
you know what it is like hanging out the
store and like all the people that are
participating in the basketball thing
what's the one thing they say about us
why we cannot win the three of us why we
can't win you Sammy and I in fighting
hey no no no it's basketball ain't
fighting could work smoking's where we
can't work we're too old too old and
like has that that's not but that's know
a thing too old I mean we are we are yes
time or we were to play the NBA yeah I
mean they're like you guys you guys are
too little no way just uncle drew this
[ __ ] guys that's what I'm talking about
wait are you referencing that
embarrassing movie poster yes dude I saw
Nick Kroll in that I was like what are
you do is he in it yeah making money is
what he's doing I guess so
you wouldn't be in a movie it looks so
Janet down like this Tiffany Haddish and
it's
she she she's in everything good for her
her part you know it's so funny about
her it looks like Laura
I used to have that poster playing a
white dude that's great oh she isn't
everything
that guy was funny move zipping it
together no she was not in she was not
in uh get out no he was funny and get
out he was the buddy well then isn't it
cronies is he doing the body Bobby
bottleservice jb smooth who was that
JB smooth he seems like a nice guy
JB Smoove yeah he lives in like an RV or
something right hard drives one around
it's great for vodka is that Kyrie
Irving yeah yeah I'll go Jewish Kyrie
Irving yeah I think so yeah who's JB
Smoove JB Smith was just the old guy and
he's a black comic oh he's the
barbershop guy man it's too bad they've
never done a black people doing
characters in a barbershop there Shaq
you see that video [ __ ] so Shaq snoring
my dad loves black movies no he loves
him really yeah my dad loved them late
Medea and all that [ __ ] he watches it
all mine really really
he's his old southern white guy and he
loves black movies wait did you guys see
that guy in the in the summer league
shooting on her hand yeah really
free throws shooting 70% which is bad no
not for a center it's not knowing oh
okay okay guys free throws we have a
call somebody on the bed DSi celebrity
hot line celebrity hot line bet DSi
celebrity hot line you were on the air
Dice Clay everybody's Andrew yeah I just
saw him at a barbecue it on a July 4th
over a wind Raider sounds like Jay was
there were you rifling through his
affairs I was not I was
yeah I know homo Kido that's true the
host is one again host was gay the other
was was uh the word I don't want to use
that you'd like to use a lot who turn
asker it's almost like the time you had
to ride the bus right you left because
it was over we're all gonna get pizza I
thought the way you talk yeah what am I
just catching up and saying how she's
doing
you put the sawfish down there your bed
I put the what sausage sausage down
there your pad and you told her to eat
it
ari is that true you put a sausage down
your pants you told Eleanor to eat pigs
head down near my pants is that correct
I told him I was doing an hour of my new
hours about Judaism
Ari Shaffir a Jew and uh and he was like
oh yeah you got to get ready for
interviews saying you're like Jackie
Mason I'm like well I don't really know
about checking mate I really like Cena
stuffers yeah I'm sure no one will know
about that no one will hear about Jackie
Mason you're ripping off Jackie Mason it
talks a lot about Judaism Jack bass oh
yeah well Andrew why are you so mad at
me you're not going out with Eleanor
anymore if I want to say suck my [ __ ]
dick [ __ ] what why can't I [ __ ] say
that you have nothing to do she's not a
good girl Andrew she's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's a dumb [ __ ] she's a Philly garbage
she was fairly trashed and you know it
the fact that you made her a legitimate
woman was a short time one-time thing
she's back to being a [ __ ] what look
at Jackie Mason on the left to pay oh
that's like Sammy Sosa it does I mean
oh great once again I'm shoving up
Eleanor's vagina oh she won't have you
anymore will she Andrew that's what half
of this angers from this she won't take
you anymore she's a good girl so
goodness true dice huh he posts a
picture of on your Instagram guys yeah I
told Christine a dumb [ __ ] Armenian
[ __ ] to bring fingerless gloves for Jay
I did that right now yes MV tour SMD
tore that dice
big fan you've called into the show a
few times but I I seem to not recall
perfectly but didn't already do
something like when he was hanging out
at your place or something over this he
said I'm late and we gonna been over it
I think it's nothing new to talk about
with that really it's it's two places
ago he's not even there anymore but but
you that's what it was rifle through
their affairs everything's about that
rings about I actually did accuse me on
the phone when I was telling what this
barbecue he's like you're a faith I'm
like how am i FIFA is steel anything was
no no no that's fair that's fair know
your group but you're not a thief I'll
take it no you're an idiot you know [ __ ]
about fighting untrained completely he's
a [ __ ] all he's got his [ __ ] rage at
his father was stabbed to death in front
of him if that's what picture what
picture what are you talking about
picture the way he's like you tell me
when and I do it he looks frightened
when you say other guy which other guy
are you referring to dice you know the
white guy with the glasses
O'Neil oh yeah Ryan Ryan O'Neal yeah
yeah so ever he is even nobody to me
yeah okay I mean you know there's no
reason to say that he didn't call you
out or anything you're just you're
bringing him up I know who this Porto
Rican guy is either but you know he's in
New York Dyson you have to take the bus
one time I I think I recalled that story
no no no we've already been so you don't
think you don't think O'Neil has a
chance in this I think he's going to
dominate Gomez I do
I think O'Neill winces $40,000 on gaming
oh don't do that
Gomez gay man interested we did do
Madison just think you did do i do
Madison Square this guy I don't know why
he plays for square
wavy gravy bro mm-hmm what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] look who just goes to the gym
and says see I'm against I don't take
pictures O'Neil shows no pictures he's
[ __ ] training you didn't have a sweat
Gomez always got at that [ __ ] Puerto
Rican tank top on I think O'Neill wins
is pretty good I did not have the potato
salad was it good did you have dice when
it is your show did you have the
cinnamon toast crunch what are the SD
our show and not not [ __ ] bonfire
interesting I mean I think he's copying
you he's copying your style I don't know
if you get offended by people stealing
from you no he loves that I mean I know
you and somebody wears the Finglas we
join your act yeah I doesn't think I
need to reach around with the cigarette
yeah yeah when he smokes on stage was
just a lot wheels wheels wheels I was
wondering if you were there is that
wheels we get a tour of a wet look at
this look at this Super Bowl a sky
collar just like you dice you don't
think that's you don't think it's a
[ __ ] you think it's an accident the
high collar the fingerless glove back
wearing the attitude you know from I'm
vaping at home I never thought I'd hear
those words come out of your mouth dice
I bet I bet that gets dicey can you
imagine wearing leather boxers like an
entire day like hiking wrong city just
yeah just taint sniff I don't know what
he's doing anymore yeah I mean he's he's
mocking you
I think he's either copping you or
saying like I think his character on
stage like look at me I'm a such a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and then his he was like what do I pick
out as a costume for that and he was
like oh I know this [ __ ] [ __ ] from
the ad that's his words not mine I said
this [ __ ] from the 80s who was big on
an unfairly big in the 80s unfairly yeah
bring the hammer guys guys I know you're
there with with wheels and hanging out
and doing your normal thing but from
what I understand you've been hanging
out with Tony Hinchcliffe a lot is Tony
there yeah let's talk to him for a
minute because I want to talk to him
about this basketball situation we got
going on
hey horseface they want to talk [ __ ] his
horse I am preparing to play three on
three
what do you normally do hey [ __ ] on one
on one sometimes I play she watch why
does everything you say sound like a gay
orgy
I am the bet you're the best yeah LeBron
came to LA to be close to is that right
find her Tony head cook believes he's a
heterosexual it looks like you got
drained all of these cameras are from me
let's take a drain by the brain bug of
Starship Troopers yeah with the AIDS
oh I'm sorry chef Cooper's good [ __ ]
got the AIDS is aids aids has AIDS
infects table bathrobe adam lanza is not
eating well hot bath brother somebody
responded bathroom poodle soup did that
shooting the rotting kill courses those
kids are aging great freddie mercury's
corpse still walks the earth now it's
red like a lobster
he looks like an experiment you'd find
in a vault in one of those fallout
videogames steve-o and more aged that's
Tony I'm proud of you I'm proud of you
Tony it looks like he looks like the
zombie some I am Legend but with hair
I'd let him suck my dick if I wasn't
afraid of ehh I wish I was there they go
up a little bit I wish it was there in
the front of the court to throw acid in
his face just this is my cell from him
well Becca I'd let him suck my dick oh
yeah I thought wasn't refer to the AIDS
Wow watch my three-pointer Tony you
don't have the arm strength do you even
get the ball to the hoop this guy says
Jesus Christ is that edited you can't
believe the photos it looks like Sarah
Jessica Parker but even more
[Laughter]
these are great you're loving these
right Tony Tony here's a good well
here's a good one somebody says about
you this picture and somebody says this
looks like a preview thumbnail on a
back-alley [ __ ] theme porn site for
gays come back run this back alley give
you 20 bucks you guys won't be laughing
when I beat you in basketball oh we
might be you'd be surprised
you would be surprised who I came is me
yep Jeremiah and Patrick Ewing wow
that's pretty good team I mean Patrick
Ewing was not great at the end but I
still believe he'll be good well
Jeremiah is out because his broken arm
oh yeah so you have a mystery person now
a lot of people Tony feel like it should
be you Josh Martin and Redman I've been
yeah yeah you know because you guys all
created the show together
it's only a band for sure but what why
are you not having read ban on your team
Tony red band tore his ACL there's no
way it's worth chicken bone and he
didn't realize it was a ratio no
breakfast as it run or done anything ACL
tear worthy a decade he's on the keto
diet what are you doing good question
what are you in dice doing are you guys
working on something I'm teaching him
wrestling I'd love to see that what I
just diced would pummel you
oh and love and love every minute of it
yeah he would make your hand punch so
mean to him weekend and then Tony write
that for you it's a good rest joke
for Comedy Central who's the guy that
doing this Willis I believe the new one
they're working on yeah you call them
Bruno is Bruce Willis Bruno you call me
Noah asked if you knew his daughters
that's a rumor and then you answer the
question that no one asked when is it
clear is Jill a necessary anymore
how about me what edge that's a good one
for Jeff rod no that's a terrible one
yeah I don't know how you were ever
famous to be honest I'm still famous
Valerie catch me in the movie
catch a rising star with all those other
actors what other actors are in it Oscar
winners yeah you seem to Bradley Cooper
Bradley Cooper yeah big-time
yeah Jill silver linings playbook maybe
yeah yeah sounds like a good lineup
Wow Benicio Del Toro's my movie with you
they must have been like what the [ __ ]
baby
just as this summer in Los Angeles it's
taping yeah yeah that they were writing
it right now like the last like two
weeks Bill Cosby's in the movie oh yeah
oh that's here hey telling I've heard
you talk about your Bill Cosby joke more
than I've heard your book ah good joke
oh go ahead that happens the punch line
is jell-o pudding oh I won't tell you
the joke but that punch line is jell-o
pudding yeah welcome dice what do you
think the chances are for for the Lakers
this year
all right it poured out of and that
being said I mean what I mean we don't
have to talk about the elephant in the
room which is Mexico got beat in the
World Cup but yeah they were still in it
oh they were in England Croatia
by the way France and Belgium damn
Russia's out Russia lose too they lost
you Croatia
like yeah two days ago you did a great
time for islands to hang out on beaches
and you know and and for me like
obviously we have beat up on it all the
time on social media that we're not big
football slash soccer about but it is
exciting to get into it and it's
exciting to to watch and to try to get
behind and the thing I didn't want was
Russia to win why because they're the
host city yeah and they are notorious
for cheating yeah they cheated in an
Olympics two years in a row they've
cheated some like the children in the
last US election they're the reason
Trump is president what does it happen
with that it's been over a year and the
Obamas he was elected was like we have
we know for a fact they meddled and
we're going to release this and now it's
been a year and a half they haven't
released any information other than this
guy lied in his hearing
well they it's just like it seems like
they keep trying to squash it and with
you but it's like why not just release
to the people it sounds like this what
what about that is American yeah it's
what about that isn't lying to the
public and trying to [ __ ] placate
that's it don't release that stuff
because they want to be able to tell
like if you may said they know for a
fact so at that point it's like sure
we'll just really not like we have
reason to believe we're gonna look into
it more it's like we know it happened so
it's like immediately just shows well I
think they think it would help the
people get their story straight like
everybody you're gonna wait for four
years till he's out of office nobody
gives a more exactly what'll happen well
dude they want it over with - I mean
Trump would rather than just go ahead
and say what they have I mean we had a
president that had polio and nobody knew
it they would stage him like brick and
burnings he would get up out of a
[ __ ] wheelchair and to have his
[ __ ] forearm braces and leg braces
and then he would stand by a
and then he would talk for some reason
Ari is now naked and was just trying to
[ __ ] Johnny like something about Johnny
just turned re on and he's like you know
what I got it's a monkey I got to be
inside you well guys speaking of
speaking of sponsors if you guys get a
chance and you want to bet on the World
Cup you want to bet on USC which I can't
wait to talk about 226 we'll get to that
hey Beth es I can take bets but sponsor
for a minute let's just talk about how
easy to bet on Betsy si it is great
we'll do a response in a minute but uh
you guys if you do want to make pets
pets es eyes this crazy new betting
website is not new they've been around
for a hot mess yeah it's just a blur
reliable I would say actually that's
exactly how I described them you can
find them on the web which is nice or
maybe an access that's an Internet right
let's say you don't live in America and
you're like how would I get to this what
about bet deicide you that would work
too I bet so let's try putting in bet
they said that au for Australia
well there's you look at that really fat
bank right so it comes up World Cup
because that's what people are betting
on you can bet on baseball you can bet
on anything you can bet on 227 which is
gonna be in LA no EU and that's
Dillashaw rematch [ __ ] them and guys go
to bet DSi come use the code punch 25
and I get you 25 free bucks to bet with
bang you don't have to do anything but
put in your [ __ ] information and then
$25 to bet with you can do with it as
you please make 25 $1.00 bets
I wouldn't do that so not stupid I would
do I would go all-in on some sort of
crazy parlay and see if I can't win
that's what I did yeah and I can't so
yeah yeah right and did you really I
made late for because you had to roll it
over a little I made like four bets and
they all just one one one one one one
yeah and then what have you so you had
it was just as many five three dollars
and then
bang a couple weeks later you have 250
bucks yeah well sometimes they'll
sometimes they'll send you an email to
say like hey here's 25 free bucks to
come back to the site come back to the
site wow really yeah Wow and they
proactively give you more money later
wow we're giving you 25 free ones as a
Jew I don't think we can accept them as
a sponsor anymore to believe well then
I'm glad you're only on this show every
[ __ ] 90 days [ __ ] seven times a
year that's true that's true
so go to bed DSi our good friends there
they're one of our longest-running
sponsors we love them and they are great
and all they're doing is giving you free
money to gamble with and if you're
listening to the show you're obviously
some sort of degenerate mm-hmm you have
some sort of gambling drinking drug
problem or something or there's no
reason you should you should come our
Luck's right now combined you should be
at work drinking gettable yep mm-hmm I
love that yeah I mean they do it in
Vegas they always bring you free drinks
if you're gambling that is true that
because they want to keep you gambling
and so do we all right Betsy si.com can
we do the read now story 125 yeah no we
don't have time for reading yeah that's
yeah we won't do our sponsorship but I
you can go there and use that and are
you ready are you hungry
you've already had some cinnamon toast
crunch and spit and then you tried to
[ __ ] my buddy over here my cinnamon
toast but are you ready to eat crow are
you I'm never ready for that but what
are you I remember a certain somebody a
week ago saying I do not respect Daniel
Cormier because he's never beaten
somebody with a belt no no you were top
queue it up anyway exactly said no but
I'll said until he beats a champ I don't
think he's a champ
did he you finally did it and then you
can just say that back quickly in
passing you said it's a battle of two
chefs like it's not until that guys beat
in a chair up he's not a chair I said
I'm rooting for him I would like to see
him actually be a champion you said that
yeah
so now great he's a champion I've rooted
for him he's a champ you went into more
than a fight yeah I wanted him to
finally be a champion instead of just
being awarded something I even even even
going into that say he couldn't win I
said he had never been a champion before
you just dissed him my previous yeah I
just dissed the [ __ ] title that
they've handed to him he never earned it
but now he's earned it
congratulations ok now you're a
respected heavyweight champion not light
heavyweight not light heavyweight champ
which you were never a champion of but
heavyweight champion congratulations you
can retire now as a champion do you
think and by the way I would like to say
and extend a congratulations to Daniel
Cormier for accommodating nobody do you
most people call them DC but I respect
the [ __ ] out of him even just going like
you know what light heavyweights like it
is what it is for some reason you got to
have like you're getting your dick out
right now do you have a buttons oh your
balls are [ __ ] yeah ok I mean I mean
you can come back to us are you you
you're going naked from the waist down
scraps are you going to naked from the
waist down
yeah not completely just I mean I was
gonna say I will if you will but short
right hand clip some wins and now they
have this whole stage thing with lesser
I know he's constantly like I got my
king you're fired I gotta I can't get
fired
let me see your [ __ ] snacks [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] junk out let me see
what you're working with look at that
dude Jabba the Hutt with your balls like
the bat-signal it looks like one of
those Apes with the [ __ ] big under
around your [ __ ] snacks pun intended
when it's normal doesn't hang that much
does it hang that much it looks like the
pig barn dude human face I'm not kidding
I'm not kidding me like I've heard you
know you always hear comments about your
own [ __ ] whatever like I was here
like hey you have a very nice dick you
have a very nice guy I hear that I've
never seen balls like this dude
I'd watch I've watched a lot of prior
being look look look look look
what's that you have veins under your
bed you have problems and you know that
vein right there like that's like you
have varicose veins in your balls
[ __ ]
you have varicose veins in your balls
balls your balls you're not doing any
Manik I'll go right to the right to the
camera we can show the balls [ __ ] no
trim you know his question is do you
trim your everything and your answer was
no I [ __ ] change my appearance something
that's well no I mean I would do it just
because it was yeah manicure [ __ ]
Queer Eye for the straight guy I [ __ ]
it's a great show you your balls looks
silly listen man you remember when the
in a you know what's that movie the
ghost when they were like making a clay
and they're like is your [ __ ] balls
look like the clunk of clay that just
got slapped on a thing that people are
trying to mold into something well I
love you too always dick but um it's not
a flattering angle at all I mean that
your butts the balls that I'm concerned
with the dick is just weird why you
realize no you didn't realize you did
realize he's like a chimpanzee
you really are like a 2-minute e by the
way have you guys read or are you
spinning us stop punching your dude
you're a little bit of a
Kasturi or maybe a sadist like you like
the heart so you're like I say this you
like this like that's good I respect
that you know the dick slap across the
face you're starting it hard no no no no
no no no no no stop beating off dude
your start I'm literally looking just
like a mushroom head and now lose that
bad look at this guy's
stop it you so happy and I love the
magician thing like arise my child rise
no no stop
re stop beating off he's like nine
different moves like he's like petting
it like a dog you want to see this on
patreon smile for patreon all right
there we go
do what happens when like let's say you
look good now you cut no no no no no wow
she says vehicles thank you so much
extra skin that looks like what earth
look like for ligh of it before anything
happens like that no no I don't even
have balls
I mean least that kind of a friend did
you guys read these things I don't know
why cuz he said gorillas Coco yeah she
does sign language yeah she dodge like
40s I think that's [ __ ]
I think the signing thing is [ __ ]
though I think it's like cold reading
you know the psychics do I think it's
very repeat well because it's not real
sign language it's like a varied version
of some more chimps and I think it's
like the [ __ ] the the interpreter is
just making up a lot of that [ __ ]
I really do I read it I read about and
the linguist say that they really don't
think chimps can learn like all that
[ __ ] I mean it's not a chimp
well she had that kitten that she loved
apparently well had it Coco Fergus
whether it's true or whether it's really
what's up we just tinfoil hat in cocoa
you did know we don't know yeah no it's
not but I mean I've read like I'm of
course yes there's a lot of but whether
it's true or whether it's false
what what one funny thing one funny
article I read because after after she
passed yeah 50 year-old gorilla whatever
it MRSA there's all these stories that
have come out of like different things
that there are trainers and different
people had communicated with and
apparently this gorilla was very well
just like would [ __ ] with you and like
cap had a spoon and kept bending spoons
would Bend the spoons and they kept
saying or signing to don't do this but
she was doing it to [ __ ] with them and
then they realized if I say the opposite
so do that and then go
we love you doing this please keep doing
this and then she quit
bending the spoons and we just kissed it
at the spoon she would just kiss the
spoon when they go home please keep
bending the spoons we love this and then
she would just kiss the spoon like her
huh no some little things like that but
what was so funny is apparently Coco the
gorilla hated birds really hated birds
like birds were the worst I respect that
and would say an insult Coco would say
you're you're you're a bird you're a
bird when Coco would be mad she would
call you a bird and then you're like I'm
not a bird they would sign back you're a
bird you're a bird and she would say I'm
a gorilla this is what gomorrah bird
this is what got me out on they turned
her into like a political message for
climate change no no no that is true no
no no put if on our green screen in the
woods this isn't true at all but none of
this is true i am nature no this is all
[ __ ] that's just a but that's how
that's edited like if you read a lot of
like the way i've read a lot of like
scientific i'm sure you have your like
but that's but that's just coca knows
the word but that's just silly
absolutely not cocoa sorry oh by the way
by the way re uh a certain friend of
ours
boom-shaka-laka he's glad that you're
back because
he apparently says you need to correct
his grammar and his spelling yeah oh I I
was you know that hurt he likes to uh I
did it once and that was probably a
mistake
so you missed your flight you miss your
flight and then you so you were here a
day later got in last night the uber
driver went the wrong way kept going the
wrong way in the counter get higher and
higher and higher
and then at summer I did call my sister
my manager system buddy hey can you see
if there's any other flights you say the
airport the whole time feeling like fun
wait wait you had to call who my
managers assistant mm-hmm you got a
whole team don't you and anyway she was
looking and I was like he's just like
gee mister like I'm for sure gonna -
we're not going but and then the end the
guys like I'll give you five stars you
give me five stars and I was like yeah
man sure and then I was like no I'm
giving the guy three stars and then I
forgotten I did if I back what's the
least amount of stars you've actually
kept going they're like turn left he's
like I'll turn right and you just keep
saying like okay chillin that's here and
kept passing it turn left here passing
and they would go for 13 for 14 for 17
there's a time when you would allow
anything it would be how to give the air
just follow the [ __ ] ways but the
problem is he's their former cab drivers
and they won't do it their own way is
that what it is in New York that's why
there are two ways to go always because
here it says stop traffic it's you get
away here it's just actors I know it
unless it's all traffic II and then
we're [ __ ]
I don't think some people realize ways
takes into account the traffic yeah it's
like I think most I mean Google Maps
does 45 minutes at JFK is like oh that's
exceptionally long let me get going and
then instead it took an hour and 10
minutes cuz this gun I 120 you just
crying why five stars what a mess I'll
give you five stars I give you like Nana
nah man
if I they're bad I just don't give them
a rating I usually don't even just
participate in their no never
it's pretty rare what's a couple times
like you know when I will sex I know
when I will tip you know when I will
test when I'm like him it's late at
night and it's like to some of them I
dude swing through Wendy's yeah
I won't tip but I'll be like I'll buy
you whatever you want you know like your
hunt it's like 2:00 a.m. you want a
burger or whatever I'll blow up to 160 I
feel bad whatever but that's not really
me tipping let's tip but one time I
moved in with tapering like from the
very beginning that's what you happen
yeah your story whenever they allowed it
I mean I probably didn't get the app
until maneuver the first time I got in
uber was two years ago
what a play caning phase I tip but I'm
I'm a good person
oh that means there how's your wife how
is your wife it's great lower why he
kind of ghosted me she kind of ghosted
really well I knocked up no no no well I
mean I'm definitely spraying inside of
her but she's not no but are you guys
are trying to have kids right yeah how's
that going
I mean it's you know that's happening
you know you got to come in her for that
to happen pretty sure yeah yeah yeah
they did my hair right see that's where
yours that's why you're swinging for the
fences and I do like that but there's I
think there's something wrong with her
plumbing because when I say I've been
[ __ ] hammering her to spray down ah
she's full-on like if she could have a
child she would have by now would you
compare to where you based on how much I
put in earth would you compare what
you're doing to the dispersal of black
people doing a civil rights movement
that's exactly what a you've got you see
my tattoos no good hose-down yeah of
course I get old hose down
I've even released the dogs and I don't
even say that a lot of people that I
don't love but so that's what you play
it's going good so it's going good then
Aaron right yeah what will you name what
will you name your kid and what
character on this show will it be based
on how about never hose down it's gotta
be teeb well TEB that's cool I mean that
would be good I mean it could be
tbh Naismith it could be Regis filth bin
forgot about that one too
every time these pottery can catch the
people missed you a nice mess actually
TV news people I get tweets about that
at least wants a you do yeah it's weird
well on patreon I know I do caller
you're on the air caller you are on the
air no color okay there is yeah here's
one here we go caller you're on puncher
where are you what's up oh [ __ ] why I
bet [ __ ] I got two questions one what
bet is any bet being paid off this
episode there's no not yet
but I mean we've seen are his balls
extensively so I think something
happened there triple he's not in he's
taking a hiatus the hotdog bun will be
paid off after that oh yeah Ari thinks
you can't pay it off until Sam pays it
off I could it's just like wait Sam's
lived out there Sam might leave the
podcast forever
for real like B just being a [ __ ] or
you know he's over it nice tweets sent
him tweet he's a break if he doesn't get
a break he's a break completely so he's
take he's taking a hiatus and I will see
where we visit in like a month or two I
think is a I think there's a massive
problem with somebody on this show I
won't mention who that is Ari what's
your second question you're the problem
I can't take a joke it's not really a
question can't take a joke well is he
always like that oh I think you mean I
see what you mean where are you calling
it cut where you're calling from call
Netta Popish lisa place like him having
trouble with being the butt of a joke is
that a new thing for it no I'm I don't
think he ever was really the butt of
jokes now yeah that's that's and that's
why it's new
he's always been the Disher and then
line him up will smoke him I got my
smoke list let him follow my smoke yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's just a guaranteed
reply on Twitter that's why they really
stick him on your rise out of them so
it's like it keeps working it's a
guaranteed reaction if you really want
the show you continue tweet him nice
things right now seriously you'll like
it
any people hasn't blocked you you can
see yeah yeah I've got so many messages
like this you still have the punch-drunk
account yeah he can do he can block
people from his own but he can't block
from a punch bunk anymore I meant to say
that last night at the patriarch he's
got to give that up for sure you could
take care of that but like he can't have
that you can't just be banning people on
the punch-drunk account let him follow
the account yeah well somebody asked me
to be unblocked and I replied yeah I do
say and then Sam and then Sam was like I
can personally block somebody from your
own lot like if you're Sam's accountant
you're like hey man I don't need to see
your [ __ ] you're too negative like I
don't need to see it but you know all of
us have you as well which you do not
know this and I as well and I also do
not know this the password to the punch
we all have access to it I don't but
only Johnny and Sam really run it yeah
so a lot of times I'll see like oh I can
tell who's tweeting from the punch-drunk
okay grammar because it's blood I'm like
using some or not using some Ari and I
have never sent one tweet I have a long
time ago
yeah maybe seven years ago we started
but never I literally have never done so
it's like it's either Johnny or or or
Sam so when you get blocked oh I'd never
open the punch on your count that's a
hundred percent because you're just like
but the thing is like if you're talking
[ __ ] to him and you guys are going back
and forth and he's the one on the
punch-drunk account then and now he's in
an argument with your book by Felicia
was the intellectual equivalent of just
sticking your fingers in your ears yeah
there's a there's an element of that as
well the thing is you could just mute
the person on you wouldn't it would be
effectively the same but if you want
kind of punish them a little bit that's
why you blog somebody because they can't
see you it's me it's better punishment
if they don't know you're doing it if
they know that it's like the part of
them goes got a rise out of you yeah huh
cuz you can I guess I couldn't take it
could you
yeah that's right you know so I don't
ever want to get an attic that's art oh
it's just like a mute keep yelling keep
yelling at a building I moved away from
that's meaningless it's just it's what's
that one what keep yelling at a billion
live away from phobias it's like there
I'm taking imagine they're outside your
building oh I see that's not anymore but
that's [ __ ] that's Amazon now yeah
and you're out there protesting me at a
place I'm not even here and you feel
like you're making a difference you're
making nothing I got you and so they
don't even know that they've been got
right the mute button is the best yeah
but it's just but he's on there so much
on social what do you mean oh yes he's
on there all the time
well you know like we were saying on the
good John it's like that's his way of
checking out we all have different ways
of checking out and his is like it's
almost like being in the matrix like I'm
just going to not be in its everybody's
person alright yeah yeah Paulie you just
like Joe Holly yeah II think you're
bored at a bar before dusk off a bus
stop you just go into that and then all
of a sudden your flight is I'm what
you're talking so how is your life
different since you cut back on this was
socially present but he also has to
charge his phone every five days yeah
it's silly I'm socially present so it's
not much I mean I'd there's some text I
can write but otherwise you get through
those pretty quick and then you're stuck
in a place and you're like you look at
your phone you're like there's nothing
to do one there I've returned every text
and there's you miss it when you're like
waiting at the airport but now I feel in
that moment with like
observation or you know I I read a book
or something or magazine it's like I
don't know you just like fill your life
instead of like waste your life thing it
cuz it's not like you really got to take
care of stuff it's really just scrolling
through your Twitter at replies or see
what else you're not really doing
anything other than its bathroom stuff
it's stuff you're supposed to read on a
twin you know but now you're reading it
all day long yeah you're literally waste
trying to pass time to waste time and so
that's what we all do it's fine but like
that's what we're doing
it's like do we really want that in our
lives to be wasting all of our times be
with your I've seen people with their
kids
you know what playgrounds and then on
their phone where it's like you're
actually not present and your kids up
writing you're on your phone not paying
attention to them they see that do you
still have a girlfriend
mmm-hmm how's it going pretty good it's
been a very long time so you described
yourself as having a girl that's white
and I've known you for a long time so I
work that's why you haven't trampled
yeah cuz you like that no trim bra I've
done it before I get ingrown hairs on
the way back no you don't go close man
you know good clothes babies but really
you should be you shaved baby with a
razor
yeah straight razor that's yeah now I
would never a razor I would never like
it like a black barbershop where it's
just like ya know I tried doing with the
[ __ ] Brawn but that pinches the [ __ ]
so well you I got a good guard just yeah
they should have a dick dick setting a
dick trimmer
they have knows they have ear they have
beard and regular hair they should also
have thick hair so it is going well huh
yeah will I meet her no I mean we're in
New York Oh possibly oh yeah [ __ ] I give
her a spray down yeah dude spray downs
coming are you at the point where you're
doing like weird [ __ ] now to kind of
keep it that's the weird [ __ ] goes away
his Richard doesn't come in late his
jump off point more extreme no re does
no no no that's interesting he starts
with like a 73 which is 69 with four
other buddies let me choke you with a my
balls near but see then that's a first
date that's a first date and then like a
year later he's like you know what we
should make love or that video hey you
making love [ __ ]
are you making love are you saying the l
word yeah really yeah really nice chicks
yes
yeah time I'll give it guys they give me
money I was worried I was worried they
weren't ones cure that I'm afraid you're
gonna I'm gonna say the M word
eventually Edward married oh yes
probably not could you I just don't
think of those terms anymore I don't
Duncan Trussell get married Duncan's
always a you can ever get married are
you divorce a B fever for lust how was
it re sweating in the belly room yeah
yeah time for another one maybe maybe
your dude I just think you just hang out
with the person do you ever talk to her
yeah you know you're right now she got
religious is that right Chris or think
I'm gonna go to sermons because she was
very interesting to me very interesting
weird you know she cuz you guys had an
open mayor open missionary didn't you
had rules you guys had rules yeah and
she was always very cool and very sweet
and she would always talk to me and we
would have like interesting
conversations and then she would always
be very quick to go right now we're
having a very interesting conversation
but you're against the rules I'm like
well what do you mean what do you mean
no no because re and I have these rules
and there's no scenario where you and I
can hook up because and I'm like it's
really soon and I would go no I but I
would never want to well that's because
it was your of half [ __ ] have super op
relationship with no rules and like my
girlfriend of my wife and it's like no
I'm not looking at yeah trouble wait a
house that's exactly how I was like I
never even looked at it that way in any
way shape or form but then there were
scenarios where she would be like Oh
obviously you might be thinking that's
having our too and she liked all say
like well we're talking so opposite says
so we're both probably thinking a
percentage of us is thinking one percent
zero for me yeah and then she's like
well no it can't happen yeah yeah she
like the PowerBook just so you know no
but she did my just so you know we're
not having sex he did my first head
shots in Los Angeles did she did my head
shots and and then I gave her a spray
down no but I never was in that scenario
so I but I haven't thought about her
forever but so now she got religious and
Christian was it she from like Hawaii
somewhere crazy wonder why for like six
months ah that's what it was she brown
no like a blonde if I recall yeah but
did she came back from her why she
surprised me like three weeks earlier
something like that I was playing video
poker on the tournament and just not
gonna do it opened it I was like all
right folded a hand then I opened then
it was her it was like oh my god were
you doing home like hey and I was like
oh I'm in this tournament oh that's the
worst
okay I went back to it she never forgave
me for that she's like you just didn't
act happy that I was [ __ ] didn't see
me like six but the money turns Carmen
we're about the blob right if it's cash
game eggs book I'm out but like this was
like [ __ ] I did not handle over I should
just like give it up on that twenty
bucks or whatever it was hundred bucks
maybe you were probably far into that
right yeah I hate when my wife comes
home and I'm I hear you and your Netflix
yeah dude trust me I also hate when your
wife comes home and I'm on Netflix cuz
I'm like no I got to pause this and I'm
out of juice almost I'm not out of juice
but I tell you what the other day it was
so hot here it's been incredibly hot you
dodging you dodging yeah how hot was it
I'm not going there okay but I've been
in LA for a little bit longer than you
so like a little over prior on 20 years
no [ __ ] and and it was the hottest night
I've ever experienced in lausanne 102
yeah at 11:30 it was still a hundred and
two degrees Wow and I was a destroying
I'm doing a game joking I'm like dude
Toby you got to turn these heat lamps on
you got to get these you know because it
was so [ __ ] hot had they turned them
on it probably would have been like a
fan on you a sad orange it's a worse for
that they have those things on the
street if it's like 80 degrees at night
they turn them on the street it's a
[ __ ] he laughs yeah
yeah always on yeah you always were all
right back yeah yeah sweating my ass off
and I gotta walk another [ __ ] [ __ ] that
goddamn yeah what was that it ended up
being like 112 that day well it was 114
in Hollywood and then I heard that the
valley was like hundred 122 or 122
degrees try what's but it wasn't but it
wasn't or humidity I've never sewn
humidity here
it was just like hot it was like being
in the oven he was like [ __ ] wind it
would just come by you and you're like
[ __ ] I'm seen like they have in Israel
say that again
obscene yeah he's really [ __ ] high
there's a hot wind comes a yet it just
blows hot air like the [ __ ] subways
coming past you just hot air that's what
it's like oh good a window oh no it's
way worse yeah yeah nice boat come seen
comments hot and then seen means I don't
really know just rains you know rain
wind it's like a it's a God's fart God
God put an SBD on you SMD is a silent no
suck my dick Oh some damn sponsor or no
I was doing it I don't think so I'm
sponsor guys he'll find out by Kenneth
um we were talking before the show when
you when you got here about you don't
seem as concerned about the LeBron
problem not gonna win I don't like it
and it bothered me for a bit until I
realized like okay
in order to what I don't want to see is
the Lakers winning championships know so
if you are a three or four seed which is
what they're looking to be probably yeah
right that means you have to get through
and I believe I really believe Houston
would have beat and Golden State this
year if Chris Paul didn't go down there
were three two oh yes I agree I I
totally older than this game and then
the game after that they nobody had
calmed them down he's their floor I
agree with you on you know they're
putting up terrible shots so
let's assume they're all back you can't
talk about injury because you don't know
if it's gonna happen or not so it's a
well but something I get injured against
like well then LeBron might get injure I
don't know yep
so who knows but it was taken out injury
because yeah of course I think Houston's
the number one team I think Golden
State's a number two team or one two and
the Lakers are at best three maybe four
if there's a three seed that means they
have to get past Houston and Golden
State in the playoffs I could see them
maybe may be upsetting one of those
teams not both especially I would
believe cousins so we are talking about
now is oh yeah they finished with a
better record in them seven games ahead
of them so we had finished talking about
now is they're gonna be the three seed
for like three years in a row
LeBron's eventually he's not old now I
don't like that talk words that he's
getting old his best it's a school year
he's incredible yeah but then that's
like then they're not gonna be able to
get over those teams they're gonna get
bad draft picks and then there's me back
in the same position they are it's
harder for him to make the finals not a
championship run and and just like
people be excited for the first I'll
beat the Clippers they won't make it
past the second round of the playoffs
and so the Clippers didn't bother me
that much well you never would because
they weren't like a [ __ ] [ __ ] team
like the Lakers but so it's like so
great you're not really building a
champion of Kalat team the same like
Oklahoma City I see what you didn't and
now they're back to nothing to say where
the Clippers like oh it's all time now
but it really wasn't time they never
made it past the second round and
nothing back to nothing and so it's like
I really didn't do anything for us now
if you were a team like I don't know
that went to the finals I had a real
shot at it then that now you have some
joy they're not gonna get that joy right
III and again I hear what you're saying
and as a New Yorker you I hear it and
you're like you're conservative you see
it but your concern is there winner
they're not gonna win yeah they're not
gonna get a ring I don't have to worry
about that what my concern is is is just
the flags to vernacular to [ __ ] a
dialogue everybody talking now all the
people that finally I had to like we
were saying earlier I had another 19 20
months out of my life finally yeah where
Laker fans couldn't say [ __ ] you haven't
made two playoff
for the first 20 months five years three
years in a row five years don't sing oh
yeah
but for the finally in my lifetime you
guys haven't made the playoffs in
back-to-back seasons that doesn't happen
in [ __ ] forever back-to-back seasons
you have not made the playoffs and
finally you guys have shut up yeah
it's like if the if the Patriots didn't
make the playoffs for three years in a
row
finally Erik Marino would shut the [ __ ]
up all the other people would shut up we
got a World Cup the frame broke update
will cup that hey breaking news alerts
appear there in injury time Frances up
won 2-0 over Belgium oh they're pretty
much the same they speak the same
language - so interesting Magritte was
from the Penn cats let me know see know
seeking who we all had who we all had
Russia and so now it's the final three I
had Egypt I'm so live at England still a
minute left possibly oh really
we'll see ya there an injury-time man
somebody had France I thought mmm
I don't think yep you are right who did
Spencer Chris yep he had France damn and
they're about to be in the finals Sam
had Germany in the final same at Germany
I add English I had England I'm so alive
I should have took him Turkey to [ __ ]
with him back nanny had Japan
Kareem had Denmark Johnny had Egypt only
because I took England he like so
[ __ ] pastor is that an Aaron had
Poland and why why did you take Poland
again Aaron watch they pull it out I
either want them to win it all or scores
or have the most own goals scored
against them okay because they're polish
that's your own pull out joke right
there yep how's your wife by the way
it's great yeah I know it what's the
towels in your house full
[Laughter]
you've been going any Yankees games I
forgot that the bat was up I just rolled
back laughing and I look at the ground
there's a baseball bat and a broken
glass on the ground from the old bat I
went to 1 Yankees two A's I've not been
to any more and I won't be able to go to
any until playoffs
why mm-hmm I'm back but Friday morning
so Friday Saturday Sunday Monday and
then I'm gone on Tuesday for till
September better than Dodgers experience
with what's the game day experience like
what would you think oh it's one getting
in the line is too long the line is far
too long you mean like the standing or
get off the subway and you're like oh
cool Yankee Stadium and you like that's
of the interest right here get to walk
all the way here down some steps and so
it's getting online then go here back
forth back foot it takes like 30 minutes
once you're there to get in 30 minute
and it's like oh we're here we're here
40 minutes for the game starts I can't
go in dude that that right-field by the
way I don't watch the Yankees a lot but
they play the Braves I watch that suit
it's great the only has so many home
runs man oh the right field they also
like do the thing and the right-field
bleachers which were there the judge
they took give it up for every player
they're like really read judge and every
judge and they just tip the cap and
they're gonna do Dee Dee Dee dude and he
[ __ ] turns gets away of like during
like stoppage of play due to every
single player it's great they all
[ __ ] recognize it like thank you I'm
not a Yankees hater but that's annoying
yeah touch my dick dick just with your
tongue just touch it with your mom nose
nose nose compromised nose I see where
you're not gonna go with the tongue no
no what about those tonsils I'll touch
your dick with his tongue I see that
Lisp came back there I'll touch your
dick with his eye now you're doing on
purpose to like make fun of it but you
still Hari I'll compromise everyone calm
down
let me give you a hand job but my mouth
okay how about you touch my dick with
your dick that's key or not that is cute
what if we tie what if we tie your dicks
in a knife I did so the troops come out
so the troops coming
Kurama dick hate the troops this just in
Johnny Johnny hates the troops troops
why do you hate the troops and they're
cowards because you don't want to touch
your dick with his dick and that's why
you [ __ ] hate the troops bro you said
it pretty much well also because of
their honey hate the troops everybody
and you'd war crimes and countries that
were brown it's a troops I mean there's
that God you know what don't make that
gayer don't make that Garrett's not
appealing but let me see you put that
chapstick on your [ __ ] dick Hall Oh
let's get it going Deva what are you
doing what are you doing I'm saying yep
block block block you then I can't see
it like it's not happening because I
need to see this this is something I
need to see ari is going to now be
putting chapstick oh I see what you're
doing I said Jim let's throw this in the
mix to make that kind of like double
double block it so he's kind of but just
put chapstick on you dude don't make
this gay just put some goddamn chapstick
in your dick hole like a man why's it
gotta be gay brah just put some
chapstick why is your first what I
complete idiot go rouse alright let me
get some Oh see that's what was gonna
happen all along all a touch on your
phone you don't realize what's happening
he was looking at a screen i was trying
i've actually no uninterpreted you're
inside of him and the patreon will thank
me for that later the next thing you
know you're inside of them well guys I
feel like it was a good show yeah I'll
takes a little bit just swear to God I
would have done it
for sunblock - is that what it is sun
protection it's for sun protection yeah
I never returned it was about the carpet
in this floor I did let me get you were
about to turn and I had to piss and I
mean it was close it was I would say
6040 towards not pissing that stand up
video named Aaron was out there was a
sub in you would have been pissed off
you ever get the rest of that it's 360
video from the know I gotta get that
it's online
well something no just some of its
online oh okay we want to put the whole
episode in three how cool is that
they'll be able to look around the house
is great and we'll be doing that again
and again guys this weekend come see us
in Brooklyn if you guys are anywhere
near New York come to skank fast we're
doing to an ego to Ari Shaffir calm and
get all your skank Fest news we're dates
three in fact on three o'clock on
Saturday is the live punch-drunk I
believe we're all doing stand-up at
different situations and you know
whatever is happening there and come
hang out and look like a fear fest shirt
come to New York come hang out with your
buddies because we'll all be there's
gonna be a live punch up there's gonna
be alive are you doing your pot no I
know Sam's doing his I was not really
alive Sam's doing a so come and watch
tin foil hat Sam's doing a live tinfoil
hat and he's also going to be doing be
on track
you'll fax instruct me well yell
fact-check from the audience please it's
not sure yeah that's funny it's so hard
to listen to you sometimes when they
just start smiling that [ __ ] though
Aaron I don't know I really admire your
restraint
as there are people out there eating
children it's wrong other children are
eating children exactly children are
eating children yeah you know Jerry they
they get them young the children eaters
grows alright well [ __ ] the Lakers [ __ ]
the Lakers always DC is finally a
champion finally a champ man
relations agenda Cormier you agree Danny
you had Ari Shaffir is respect the new
heavyweight champ of the world Daniel
Cormier congratulations to you it was
exciting to see how emotional he was Ari
thank you for putting chapstick on your
dick showing us your hideous balls and
for being in the studio for once in the
last two years be nice to Sam on Twitter
please and please be nice to say I'm on
Twitter and Erin I'll see you at home
everybody else left my god can ten you
just I thought you're gonna go [ __ ] and
then you just went yeah
continue to suck it so second